lady gaga is like a cat got nine lives
we have seen so many different versions
of her she does all of the things but we
finally get pop star gaga back Mother
Monster is dropping her new single
perfect illusion her first solo record
since 2013 artpop now she hasn't been
living under a rock for say though that
would be really dope rock but here's why
we needed the new music let's not forget
her 2008 debut it got her attention it
got us to dance and it solidified her as
one of pop music's heavy hitters now it
did it for me though was her 2009 VMA
performance paparazzi you know she
wanted to create an iconic pop culture
moment and girl you succeeded I cannot
still forget the blood oh my god
[Music]
then she drop bad romance the video the
music fashion but dancing it is the bog
out we know and love fast forward to
born this way era not only does she give
us another number one single she gave us
a friggin anthem it started a movement
for the LGBT community and not to
mention gifted us with some big jams my
favorite
[Music]
dan that's a good song the saxophone
that's what a saxophone sounds like
right and then there was our pop now was
okay we did get some jams out of it and
it was classic gaga all balls to the
walls but what happened after that album
I don't think anyone expected she teamed
up with Tony Bennett in 2014 on a jazz
album what's guys cheek to cheek was
really good it earned the now bffs a
Grammy they went on tour together I saw
it and it was magical since then Lady
Gaga turned actress on us in American
Horror Story which earned her a golden
globe then she performed that epic Sound
of Music medley at the Oscars was
invited back the next year as an Oscar
nominee for her original song till it
happens to you and then she slayed the
national anthem at the Super Bowl this
year that was just enough to remind us
that ladygaga can sing and we need a new
record from her already plus she already
has her next acting gigs lined up she's
the lead in the new American Horror
Story premiering next week and is gonna
be in the remake of a star is born I
smell an Oscar she says the new album is
gonna drop this year but I'm sorry we
needed it yesterday I already have
perfect illusion pre-order but I want to
know are you guys as excited as I am for
new lady gaga music let me know in the
comments section below or tweet me at D
direct oh and be sure to subscribe to
ets youtube channel for more gaga